[Música]
un día
muy de mañana en la orilla del mar
estaba joven en lo alto de un risco
mirando una playa larga hermosa y a lo
lejos divisó una figura humana que
caminaba con unos cuantos pasos se
inclinaba y volvía a caminar otros pasos
el joven se quedó viéndolo durante
algunos minutos y le despertó curiosidad
inquietud y decidió bajar y acercarse a
ver qué estaba haciendo esa persona
cuando se acercó o vio que se trataba de
un adulto mayor de un anciano que daba
unos cuantos pasos tomaba una estrella
de mar y la regresaba al mar
y el joven los saludo buenos días señor
cómo está qué hace usted y el anciano
contento le dijo pues mire joven el día
de ayer subió mucho la marea y dejó
varadas a estas estrellas de mar si no
tocan el agua en un par de horas
seguramente van a morir y entonces las
estoy salvando
el joven escéptico e incrédulo le dijo
oiga pero esta playa es muy larga tiene
varios kilómetros yo creo que usted no
está logrando mayor cosa yo creo que
usted no está cambiando nada porque hay
varios cientos o miles de estrellas de
mar y el anciano sabio prudente
simplemente tomó otra estrella de mar y
le dijo pues mira para ella lo cambió
todo y le regreso al mar
pequeñas grandes acciones que dan vida y
que ayudan a los equilibrios de este
planeta
cuánto tiempo puede sostener el aire
cuanto tiempo aguanta sin respirar
quizás un minuto quizás dos minutos te
invito a que hagas la prueba en estos
días te vas a dar cuenta de la
importancia de tener una atmósfera y de
tener oxígeno para respirar
de la fragilidad humana y de la
dependencia del oxígeno porque no nos
damos cuenta que cada uno de nosotros al
día podemos respirar entre 21 mil y 25
mil veces lo hacemos de manera
automática e imperceptible que prefieres
respirar oxígeno limpio aire puro que te
nutra que te dé vida obtener aire
contaminado lleno de smog
cuanto valoras tener un río limpio con
aguas transparentes con peces en donde
te puedas meter a refrescar oa bañarte
a nadar o prefieres tener un río como
los hay muchos en este país con aguas
grises que huela mal con heces fecales
lleno de basura
cuanto valoras tener un bosque limpio
con árboles frondosos en donde haya aves
en donde existan ardillas y otros
animales que sea una hábitat o prefieres
tener paisajes desolados deforestados
llenos de tierra
bueno pues el aire el agua de ese río el
bosque son parte de la naturaleza son
bienes públicos bienes públicos que son
de todos y para todos son bienes que nos
igualan son bienes democráticos
bien es que tienen dos características
no rivalidad y no exclusión yo no veo a
nadie que le esté tapando la nariz a
otra persona para poder respirar nadie
nos puede excluir y no rivaliza mos a
diferencia de los bienes privados por
ejemplo tu celular si tú no pagas la
mensualidad o la ficha de tu celular te
cortan el servicio es decir te excluyen
si no compras el boleto para entrar a un
lugar y ya el cupo está lleno rivaliza
en los bienes públicos no hay rivalidad
y no hay exclusión de tal suerte que son
bienes que están ahí de todos y para
todos y debemos de considerarlos como
una extensión de nuestra casa
y esto es más importante porque en los
últimos años desafortunadamente los
gobiernos de los tres niveles de
cualquier color que sean estos y
prácticamente en todo el mundo
no alcanzan a responder ante la
problemática del deterioro ambiental las
acciones del gobierno son insuficientes
y nuestro planeta
se está contaminando se está degradando
estamos perdiendo biodiversidad
biológica estamos sufriendo
calentamiento global deforestación
basura de tal suerte que es un buen
momento para que los ciudadanos tomemos
conciencia y decidamos participar más
activamente
quiero comentar tres vías la primera es
la actividad y la oportunidad que
tenemos los universitarios para
organizarnos y mejorar los entornos de
nuestras instituciones y los entornos de
las comunidades en las cuales vivimos y
en las cuales estamos relacionados
tenemos la oportunidad también los
profesores de que esas investigaciones
que hacemos en todas las ramas del
conocimiento tengan mayor impacto en la
sociedad no es suficiente hacer papers y
hacer libros y dejarlos allí en un
estante o en una biblioteca en una
computadora tenemos la oportunidad y el
desafío de lograr que tengan aplicación
en la sociedad la segunda vertiente
platicarte la oportunidad la posibilidad
que hoy en méxico tenemos para acudir a
los tribunales ambientales para detener
a una persona oa un hecho que está
cometiendo daños al ambiente y buscar la
reparación del daño
yo soy investigador en el área del
derecho del derecho ambiental a eso me
dedico y en los últimos 10 años méxico
ha transformado sus leyes de una manera
muy importante al igual que sucede en
américa latina' y prácticamente en
cualquier lugar del mundo de tal suerte
que esta ventana de oportunidad de
acción que yo le llamo el activismo
jurisdiccional es otra gran gran brecha
o gran oportunidad que tenemos y la
tercera es lo que tú puedes hacer todos
los días reducir tu consumo de plástico
reducir tus consumos los potes
y dejar de usar vehículo particular y
utilizar transporte público bicicleta
caminar
puedes también
y controlar sus consumos de agua
la energía eléctrica y muchas otras
recomendaciones que vienen en la web
puedes organizarte con los vecinos con
tus amigos participar en ongs
ambientalistas y procurar estas acciones
de mejoría los entornos hoy podemos
hacer muchas más acciones por el planeta
es momento de cuidar la vida de cuidar
el equilibrio de cuidar la
sustentabilidad de cuidar el cambio
climático
consideremos a la naturaleza como esta
extensión de nuestra casa a la que todos
tenemos derecho no importa si eres rico
si eres pobre no importa si eres bajito
eres alto si eres delgado o eres obeso
si eres blanco eres de color la
naturaleza es un bien público que a
todos nos pertenece
es momento que elijas
elige participar lo elige activar te
elige alzar la voz y elige ponerte en
acción para defender lo que es tuyo tu
planeta y al igual que el anciano en el
mar hoy es un buen día y mañana también
para hacer acciones por el planeta
gracias
[Aplausos]